crise sanitaire canicule et départs en
vacances les causes sont multiples mais
le constat est bien là les réserves de
sang n'ont pas été aussi faible depuis
10 ans l'établissement français du sang
se mobilisent et appelle à donner
immédiatement une collecte était
organisée à l'hôtel de ville de vélizy
mercredi 14 octobre et les donneurs ont
répondu présent j'effectue ma famille ma
maman qui tient firme hier donc j'ai
rapidement les échos des besoins de sang
pourquoi je sais qu'en ce moment
particulier nous voulons pas le besoin
c'est par un sms de le fs que les
donneurs réguliers on était prévenu de
l'urgence la proximité du lieu de
collecte encourage les donneurs à venir
je viens ici parce que j'habite à côté
c'est pratique c'est vrai que quand il
faut se déplacer c'est contraignant donc
là quand il n'y a pas besoin de se
déplacer trop loin c'est pas trop
contraignant donc on n'a pas discuté et
beaucoup de demandes et voilà c'est un
geste que qu'anodin en plus j'ai
travaillé pour la mairie donc je suis à
côté faire pratiquer pour moi les
collectes continue dans les maisons du
don de la ffs et dans les collectes
mobiles organisées